un nuevo episodio en las tensiones entre
ucrania y rusia en medio de las
advertencias de los aliados occidentales
de kiev sobre una posible invasión rusa
durante el invierno el ejecutivo de
excelentes que apostó por el diálogo
para terminar con el conflicto en la
disputada zona del donbass y maple wind
debemos confesar que sin nuestras tropas
no podemos detener la guerra debemos
decir la verdad sin negociaciones
directas con rusia no podremos detener
la guerra y esto ha sido reconocido por
todo el gobierno y los socios externos
introducción con acusaciones cruzadas
ucrania señaló a los rebeldes
separatistas del donbass respaldados por
rusia por violar el alto el fuego
acordado ni hemos tenido una vida
tranquila probablemente nos hemos
acostumbrado a la situación a los
bombardeos que se producen lejos de
nosotros pero este ha sido duro y
aterrador robaba está por su parte moscú
acusa a ucrania de estar acumulando
cientos de miles de tropas en la
frontera de la península de crimea
ucrania orgánica aplica según algunos
informes su número ya ha alcanzado los
125 mil soldados si alguien no lo sabe
eso es la mitad de todas las fuerza de
ucrania tanto la otan como la unión
europea ya han lanzado una advertencia
de rusia si decide atacar a su socio del
este
hay que hacer todo lo posible para dejar
claro que cualquier agresión contra
ucrania tendrá una respuesta contundente
a response con motivo de la crítica
situación el secretario de estado de
eeuu anthony blinken y su homólogo ruso
serguéi lávrov se reunirán este jueves
para buscar una solución